hello everyone welcome to El Capitan Day
I'm pretty excited as most of you know
or some of you probably don't know
because there wasn't actually any alert
or anything that popped up that said hey
the new OS is available ready for
download but I'm downloading it right
now we're currently on vacation I was
actually laying out at the beach and I
saw on my phone that it was officially
out so I ran in the house and Here I am
so we're downloading and then we're
gonna install it and turn up so Wow El
Capitan I don't know why every time I
say I'd have to say it like that it's
downloading I'm gonna go to the beach
right now because they took my little
pup outside to the beach and they kept
running around and he's quote loving it
so let's go see what he's doing my
little baby boy we're heading back
tomorrow it's LA so he's gonna be
returning back home and he's I know what
to do cuz he had him in two different
beach houses he's traveled across the
country in a car 15 hours and now holy
crap
oh we're all steamed up now oh my gosh
it was the cutest thing baby little
froggy
there's my baby he's runnin oh there's
it's so pretty out this whole entire
trip it's raised so we haven't really
got to even go outside or do much of
anything there so I don't have to be
blogs you just kind of sat around watch
TVs no family
baby look at you doesn't care oh look at
your little nose
for heaven's sakes
look at you
daddy look
Oh looking
okay little Matt is losing his mind at
the beach baby
maybe had so much fun abortion now back
inside for a happy time hair on point
okay let's see here
install Gen June Stahl I'll copy Tom are
you gonna look like if I got my hair
chopped short not continue agree agree
install oh gosh
26 minutes I've got things I need to do
like sit on Twitter if I could do that
on my phone house a long time 26 minutes
computer is restarting okay it did the
whole process and now we're back to ten
more minutes hurry up Jen tell us about
your phone like I can't even turn it
back on is there you just got it you
just got it for anything well good news
my phone is we can't my computer's ready
what are you gonna do so here's some of
the new El Capitan changes they've got
this is what I'm really excited about
okay is the split screen you'll go to
split screens if you're working on a
document and you want to be doing
iMessages clearly that's what you've got
you doing here this is pretty cool call
out your cursor so you just shake it
look at this you see it documents I
worked on last week
I don't ever actually use the mail I
just use straight up Gmail how to do
flip the screen the vs. to click and
hold the green fullscreen button okay
our other thing yeah oh this is so fast
you actually do like that a lot because
a lot of times I'll be editing and
looking over here on the other side for
changes to make for videos so that's
gonna be kind of cool I like it that's
pretty neat
thanks for watching let me know what you
guys think of the new OS let me know
what you guys think of the new OS on the
phone on the watch a lot of new stuff
with Apple coming out I'm looking
forward to the new iPad pro also
surprisingly looking forward to the
Apple pencil especially to use that with
the new iPad pro is gonna be kind of
cool so I'll see you guys later I hope
you're doing awesome Hey look there's
Bri Bri did you update to the
os yeah but you didn't on your computer
your computer in case you missed she
said she turned her computer on for the
first time in years when was that
I blocked that shot like I can't name a
single basketball player do it